ahora obtengamos un poco de práctica
sumando números mixtos digamos que
quiero sumar 2 y 4 séptimos + 3 y 2
séptimos
te recomiendo que le pongas una pausa
del vídeo y lo intentes por tu cuenta
cuánto vale
esta suma bueno pues hay varias formas
de resolver esto y una de ellas es
simplemente tomar las partes enteras de
estos números mixtos y sumar las dos más
3 es 5 y luego tomar las fracciones de
los números mixtos
y sumarlas y 4 séptimos más dos séptimos
son seis séptimos
séptimos ahora un momento como hice esto
de separar los enteros y las fracciones
y llegué a este resultado pues vamos a
ver lo paso por paso aquí este número
mixto 2 y 4 séptimos se puede escribir
como 2 + 4 séptimos y el número mixto 3
y 2 séptimos se puede escribir como tres
más dos séptimos conquer y aquí lo único
que hice fue reescribir estos números
mixtos 2 y 4 séptimos + 3 y 2 séptimos
es igual a 2 + 4 séptimos más tres más
dos séptimos
y esto lo podemos ver como bar podemos
cambiar estos dos números de lugar y nos
queda dos más tres más
+ 4 séptimos 4 séptimos más dos séptimos
más dos séptimos y luego podemos ver
fácilmente que dos más tres dos más tres
es igual a cinco y cuatro séptimos más
dos séptimos es igual a seis séptimos
walker pero bueno ahora vamos a hacer un
ejercicio de números mixtos un poquito
más interesante digamos por ejemplo que
ahora tenemos tres y tres quintos más
cinco y cuatro quintos esto a cuánto es
igual y bueno podemos hacer lo mismo que
en el ejercicio pasado tomamos los
enteros
+ 5 y 35 son 8 y luego tomamos las
fracciones tres quintos más cuatro
quintos y esos son siete quintos ahora
esta respuesta no está mal tres y tres
quintos más cinco y cuatro quintos si es
ocho y siete quintos pero está un poco
extraña nunca hay porque siete quintos
es más grande que uno siete quintos es
mayor a un entero entonces si queremos
tener una mejor idea de qué cantidad
representa este número
tenemos que reescribir lo que tenemos
ocho enteros más siete quintos pero
siete quintos lo podemos escribir como
la suma de cinco quintos que es un
entero más dos quintos no queráis cinco
quintos más dos quintos es siete quintos
de qué nos sirve escribirlo así pues nos
sirve porque esta fracción de aquí cinco
quintos es un entero y aquí lo que
tenemos es 8 + 1 que son nueve más dos
quintos ok o sea nueve y dos quintos lo
único que hice en este ejercicio fue
hacer esta suma de números mixtos de la
misma forma que hace unos cuantos
minutos con los otros dos números mixtos
pero luego me di cuenta de que la
fracción de este número mixto es más
grande que un entero entonces pues lo
dividía en la parte entera más el resto
de la fracción y pues junte ese entero
con los otros enteros de este número
mixto y así obtuvimos el 9 y bueno pues
aquí tenemos el resto de la fracción ok
ocho y siete quintos es nueve y dos
quintos porque este siete quintos es un
entero más
quintos esta suma escrita de una forma
más clara es nueve y dos quintos y otra
vez si me preguntas oye como obtuvimos
un 9 es aquí tres más cinco es ocho pues
obtenemos el nueve porque tres quintos
más cuatro quintos es siete quintos que
es más grande que un entero entonces
separamos el entero y lo ponemos en el
lugar de los enteros sumándose con
nosotros ocho enteros